latin à nous c'est une première pour
Sylvain dimanche 11 septembre les
apprentis enquêteur récolte des indices
avec sa famille il participe au rally
surprise organisé par le Lions club
d'lencour au profit de l'association
andyien c'est l'ambiance et apprendre
des choses et puis passer un bon moment
voilà pu en plus on peut a plus une
bonne cause donc c'est encore mieux ça
c'est encore pas mal avec des énigmes à
résoudre en équipe les 40 participants
découvrent Vall de la Bièvre et ses
curiosités différentes étapes ponctuent
le parcours jusqu'à l'ancienne mairie
d'élancour un moyen de s'amuser tout en
faisant une bonne action il s'agit de
financer le don d'un chien on a choisi
un jeune handicapé on a pas je peux pas
vous dire encore si c'est un malvoyant
un autiste mais c'est ce type de profil
que l'on vise également les
schizophrènes pour lesquel l'utilisation
du chien est très importante c'est
au-delà du chien d'aveugle là on est
plutôt sur des personnes avec un
handicap moteur et le chien peut
accomplir des petites tâches comme
ouvrir une porte ouvrir le frigo pour
aider les les personnes cette
manifestation a permis de récolter
environ 600 € un chien d'assistance
coûte 15000 € il faut en moyenne 3 ans
au club pour recueillir les fonds
nécessaires à ce type d'opération
d'autres événements solidaires sont
organisés toutes l'année très détendu ça
va